bienvenue sur votre chaîne de
vulgarisation politique la chaîne qui
vous expliquent nos institutions
françaises
aujourd'hui on va vous parler du conseil
constitutionnel donc déjà je vous
rappelle que toutes les normes doivent
respecter la constitution qui est notre
norme suprême en france sachez qu'avant
1958 il n'y avait pas d'organisme pour
vérifier que la loi respecter la
constitution
il faut dire qu'en france la loi est
considéré comme l'expression de la
volonté générale du peuple qui s'exprime
par le parlement donc on considère que
mettre en place un organisme qui
pourrait la remettre en question c'est
un peu comme remettre en cause la
volonté du peuple
et autant dire que remettre en cause la
volonté du peuple dans une république
ça le fait pas trop mais quand la
constitution pour le changement de
république est écrite en 1958
les constituants donc ceux qui écrivent
la constitution en ont assez d'avoir un
parlement qui s'occupe de tout et qui
légifère sur tout comme c'est le cas
sous la quatrième république
ils définissent donc la loi ne doit
s'occuper que des domaines très
importants comme les libertés publiques
le droit de réunion le droit syndical ou
encore la liberté religieuse
enfin globalement des grandes questions
mais pas des détails comme par exemple
la taille minimum des poissons qui sont
autant il est pêché dans tel ou tel
rivières ce genre des questions peut
être décidée par d'autres organismes que
le parlement il n'y a pas besoin d'une
loi qui mobilise tout le parlement pour
prendre cette décision
pour résumer les fondateurs de la
constitution de la vème république
voulait que la loi qui est défini dans
l'article 34 de la constitution soit là
uniquement pour traiter l'essentiel
le conseil constitutionnel a donc été
créée par la constitution du 4 octobre
1958 pour vérifier que le pouvoir du
parlement n'empiète pas sur celui du
gouvernement ou de l'administration
il est mis en place en 1959 et au départ
c'est une petite institution qui n'a pas
beaucoup de pouvoir
au fil du temps il s'est transformé et
son champ d'action s'est agrandie il est
devenu le juge de la constitution et
c'est lui qui contrôle le respect des
lois au droit et aux libertés
fondamentales qui sont dans la
constitution le conseil constitutionnel
contrôle obligatoirement toutes les lois
qui précise la constitution ou qui font
directement appel et qu'on appelle les
lois organiques pour les autres lois il
faut faire appel au conseil
constitutionnel pour qu'il examine alors
bien sûr le président de la république
le premier ministre et les présidents du
sénat et de l'assemblée nationale
peuvent le saisir aussi 60 députés ou 60
sénateurs peuvent se regrouper pour
demander au conseil constitutionnel son
jugement sur une loi qui va être votée
ça permet aux partis d'opposition de
faire aussi appel au conseil
constitutionnel et depuis peu tous les
citoyens peuvent demander au conseil
constitutionnel son avis sur une loi via
la question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité
constitutionnalité qpc est présente dans
la constitution
grâce à ça tous les citoyens peuvent
saisir le conseil constitutionnel
lorsqu'ils sont jugés s'ils pensent que
la loi ou l'article de loi sur lequel le
juge se base n'est pas constitutionnelle
le conseil constitutionnel peut juger
noah qui existent déjà ou une loin qui
est en cours de vote et sont dûment peut
aller jusqu'à l'annulation de la loi en
question
en plus de défendre les droits et les
libertés fondamentales
le conseil constitutionnel est aussi le
juge des élections nationales
à chaque élection il y a environ 400
recours de la part de citoyens qui
estiment que l'élection ne s'est pas
déroulée de façon réglementaire et le
jugement par le conseil constitutionnel
peut aller jusqu à l'inégibilité
temporaire ou l'annulation du vote pour
les fraudes très grave
le conseil constitutionnel c'est aussi
le juge d'appel des comptes de campagne
de l'élection présidentielle il est un
premier juge qui est spécialisée dans le
contrôle des comptes de campagne et de
financement des partis politiques
mais à la suite du jugement le conseil
constitutionnel peut être saisi par le
candidat pour faire re jugé ces cours
c'est comme ça que les comptes de
campagne de nicolas sarkozy ont été
définitivement annulées pour sa campagne
de 2012
pour finir et de façon beaucoup plus
exceptionnelle dans le cas où le
président voudrait utiliser l'article 16
de la constitution pour prendre les
pleins pouvoirs le conseil
constitutionnel est la principale
instance de contrôle car pour prendre
les pleins pouvoirs le président doit
consulter le conseil constitutionnel et
ensuite c'est aussi lui qui contrôle la
durée des pouvoirs exceptionnels du
président le conseil constitutionnel est
constitué de neuf membres élus pont neuf
ans ernould un tiers tous les trois ans
ce qui permet d'avoir une alternance
politique dans les nominations
trois membres sont nommés par le
président de la république 3 par le
président du sénat et trois par le
président de l'assemblée nationale
le mandat n'est pas renouvelable ce qui
est indispensable pour l'indépendance
des conseillers et les membres n'ont pas
le droit d'exercer un autre métier ni
d'avoir des responsabilités dans un
parti politique
pendant leur mandat ce que l'on appelle
souvent les sages ne sont pas très
médiatisé ce qui encore une fois est
nécessaire pour éviter toute course à la
popularité qui pourrait entraîner des
décisions populistes avant de prendre
leur poste ils doivent prêter serment
auprès du président de la république les
membres du conseil constitutionnel ne
sont pas forcément des magistrats
professionnels
en france ils peuvent venir de toutes
les professions
la plupart du temps le choix d'un membre
se borde vers les personnages politiques
en fin de carrière qui n'ont plus à
faire leurs preuves et qui ne court plus
après le pouvoir afin de garantir un
maximum la neutralité
le président du conseil constitutionnel
est nommé par le président de la
république les anciens présidents de la
république sont membres de droit du
conseil constitutionnel
aussi les membres du conseil
constitutionnel sont révocables en cours
de mandat voilà cette vidéo est finie
j'espère que vous aurez bien compris que
le rôle principal du conseil
constitutionnel et de veiller au respect
des droits et libertés fondamentales
c'est le gardien de la constitution et
il permet d'assurer que la norme la plus
importante de notre pays est bien
appliquée partout et tout le temps le
conseil constitutionnel n'écrit pas les
lois et ne doit pas prendre la place des
parlementaires par contre il est là pour
effacer les partis qui disent non
conforme à la constitution aux libertés
fondamentales et aux droits de l'homme
je vous remercie d'avoir écouté cette
vidéo si elle vous a plu n'hésitez pas à
mettre un pouce en l'air et à la
partager aussi venez nous rejoindre sur
facebook et twitter
on publie de nombreuses choses pour
expliquer le fonctionnement de nos
institutions
merci à tous et à bientôt